ظهورانيه لابنه الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم
جونغ اون مرتين خلال اسبوع واحد فقط كان
كثيرا باثاره تكهنات لبدايه تقديمها
للجمهور كخليفه محتمله لوالدها في حكم
البلاد الكشف عن شخصيه ابنه كيم جونغ اون
اثر اهتمام محلي لكوريا الشماليه اكثر
بكثير من الاخبار عن انطلاق الناجح لاقوى
صاروخ باريس
لم تكشف عن اسم الفتاه او عمرها ووصفتها
فقط بانها الطفله المفضله او الغاليه على
قلب والديها زعيم كوريا الشماليه اذا
شخصيه الاسبوع في صباح العربيه جو اي هو
الاسم الطفل الغاليه في وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه ابنه زعيم مملكه الغموض كما يطلق
عليها
غالبا ما اختفت النساء في حياه زعماء
كوريا الشماليه بسبب كثير من الخصوصيه
التي وصلت الى حد اخفاق حقائق حول عدد
ابنائهن او تواريخ بلادهن لكن مع زعيم
الحالي تسرب القليل او ما اراده ان يظهره
من حياته الشخصيه سنبدا بابنته محل الجدل
الحالي لؤي عام 2013 نقلت صحيفه الغامديا
عن اللاعب كره السله الامريكيه دنيا بعد
عودته من كوريا الشماليه ان زعيمها انجبت
طفله صغيره وكشف ان اسمها جو اي وصف كيم
حينها وصف بالاب الجيد هي عائلات جديده
ومنذ ذلك الوقت لم تظهر سوا في التاسعه
عشر من نوفمبر الجاري كما صور وكما في
صورها مع ابيها كنا يتحدثان مع المسؤولين
يتفقدان الصواريخ ويشاهدان اطلاق صاروخ
بالسي عابرت بعد اسبوع واحد فقط نشرت
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الرسميه مجموعه
اخرى من الصور لهما هذه المره ايضا لن
يذكر فيها عمر الف او اسمها ولكن وصفت
بانها الطفل الاحب او الاعز على قلب
الزعيم كيم جونغ اون
لقب الاول كسيد اولى في كوريا الشماليه
بعد ان كانت زوجه الزعيم تحمل لقب الرفيقه
تقاريره تؤكد انها واحده من المغنيات في
اوركسترا انهاسو ويشاري لان اعلان الزواج
لم يحدث الا بعد ان حرص المسؤولون على محو
ماضيها الترفيه من اقراص مدمجه وغيرها
معكم الان الى ثالث همم سيده في حياه
الرئيس الاخت ذات النفوذ الكبير كيم يونج
التي تتولد بارزه وتوجه تحديدات مهينه
للغريمه كوريا الجنوبيه وعندما انتشرت
شائعه و التكهنات في عام 2020 حول صحه
الزعيم الكوريه الشماليه باتيونذر لاخته
كينيون جونغ على انها نائبه محتمله لتولي
زعامه العائله والحفاظ على هذه السلاله
الى ان يصبح احد اطفال في سنن تاهله لتولي
زمام القياده
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد ينضم ليلى
دكتور سامي رماني بحث معهد رويال سيرفس في
لندن وخبير في الشعله الكوري اهلا بك مع
الدكتور سامويل ماذا عن اخت الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي والتي
يعمل على ان تكون هي نائبه في الحكم
وبعدين
اكثر منطقيه منه
فاذا توفي فجاه
فهي تدرك كل شيء وتعرف كل شيء وبالتالي
هي موجوده على مدى سنوات وقالت مؤخرا
ان الولايات المتحده ستواجهها ازمه اذا
كانت هناك محاوله لجعل الامم المتحده تهدد
بتجاربها صاروخيه وهذه الامور
ابديت على العالم ليكون هناك وضوح
نعم
اليوم اليوم ما هو السر في اظهار زعيم
كوريا الشماليه للعنصر النسائي في محيطه
الى العلم اكثر من مره نراه تاره يظهر صور
زوجته دائما هو برفقه زوجته واليوم ابنته
وايضا شقيقته التي تطفو ويطفوا اسمها على
العلم تعيين وزير خارجيه ايضا امراه يعني
هل هو عن قص ولا من باب الصدفه
وهذيك سبب
صدفه
لكنها ليست مئه بالمئه صدفه هذا هو نمط
ربما اللي يحاول ان يميز نفسه
عن ابيه وجده ويقول انه مختلف في سياق
والسياسات الدفاع
ويحقق كثير من احلامي والده بالنسبه
للتجارب صاروخيه وجعل كوريا الشماليه دوله
نوويه
اصلاحات داخليه
وكثير من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه هناك حركه
ونشاط لكنه بدا بمسائل الاجتماعيه وخاصه
الجندريه اردني نفسه مختلفا واكثر تقدما
والده وجده وهذا همم
اترك هذه هذا الارث للاجيال القادمه
نحن ونشكرك جزيل الشكر من اكسفورد دكتور
سامويل رماني بحث في معهد رويال سيرفس في
لندن وخبير في الشان الكوري
الحديث حول ما تعكس هذه الصوره عن كيم
جونغ الاب والزعيم والرجل السياسي الابرز
سيكون معنا من جده معتصم طيطي المختص في
لغه الجسد والتواصل عن بعد
طيب اهلا بك يا دكتور معنا من جديد
ولغه الجسد كيف يمكن تفسير ما يقوم به
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي باخذه ابنته معه في
معظم المناسبات العسكريه واطلاق صواريخ
باريسيا ما الذي توحي به لغه الجسد
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام الحقيقه
للوضوح الكامل في
قرب بابنه الرئيس الكوري منه جسديا يعني
قريبه جدا في الجهه اليمنى وكانت مره وفي
الجهه اليسرى تابط الكتف هذا يدل على ثقه
وحب وقرب من هذا الرئيس انا الحقيقه يعني
اود ان اخذ الحوار قليلا بعيدا عن السياسه
وما اذا كان تكهنات بانه هي اا القائد
المستقبلي او ان
السياسه الكم ايه جنديه تستمر عبر الاجيال
وكل هذه الاشارات قد تكون صحيحه
في لغه الجسائل في لغه الجسد هناك وضوح في
حياتكن من ثقته وحبه في العنصر النسائي
سواء كانت الاخت او الزوجه او الابن وعبر
التاريخ كان هناك زعماء كثيرين همم يعني
قاموا بمثل هذا منهم الرئيس السابق محمد
القذافي في الثقه من حول النساء
لانه اعتقد انه في كثير من الرجال يعتقد
ان اذا اخذنا الامر همم بثقه من من حولي
وان هذا سيغدر بي او لا يغدر به كان كيد
المراه حب وكان كيد ال- همم الرجل غيابه
جب
فهناك ثقه يعني انا اللي اللي واضح في في
لغه الجسد انه غياب اول شيء همم ملامح
الطفوله عن هذه الابن تصرفات الطفوله ظهور
الطفوله وكان في همم شيء من يعني اذا همم
نظرنا بصوره متمهله نحس انها بتكات تكون
امه
واخته الكبرى اكثر بظهرها اكثر بتصرفها
وهذا يدل على الحب يدل على همم اعطاء الحب
بالاضافه انه بشكل عام الاب همم يميل الى
همم البنت الانثى او الولد الانثى من
اولاده اكثر من الذكر من اولاده وهذا
في يعني دلالات تاريخيه كثيره لكن شبه
الاكاد يكون متطابق يجعل من الحب عامل اخر
يعني في كثير من الاحيان الابن او البنت
الذي يشبه الاب او تشبه الام الى حد ما
يكون اقرب الى قلب هذا الوالد فكل هذه
العوامل وظهوره بلغه جسد قريبه جدا تدل
على ثقته
ببنته قد تكون هي مستقبل هذه الدنيا
من خلال هذه الصور دائما لما نتحدث عن
عنوان للخوف وعنوان لكبسه زر اللي صواريخ
بالستيه صواريخ نوويه
لحاله من الغموض الذي يحيط هذا البلد لكن
هذا التناقض بين هذا هذه الصفات التي اشرت
اليها الان وهذه الحب وهذا الانسجام
واظهار النساء في حياته كيف يمكن نفهم
شخصيته ولكن
يعني انا ذكرت في اكثر من اللقاء مع حضرتك
ااا احدهم ااا اخت نادين انه هذا الرجل مع
كل القسوه الذي يحاول ان يظهر بها الا انه
فيه طفوليه بشكل ما وهذه ال ال الرغبه او
الحاجه بالحب والحنان
ويجب ان تفرغ في زاويه ما اا لذلك وجود
هذه البنت ووجود الزوجه ورغوبه او رغبته
في اظهارها رغبه همم
يكاد يكون هو المتنفس الوحيد للشخصيه هذا
الرجل هو يحتاج الى هذه الحنيه ويحتاج الى
هذا الحب ويحتاج الى هذا العطاء لذلك همم
لابد ما كانت الابنه او البنت واذا لاحظتم
همم ظهور الاخت كان ظهور منفرد لم يكن
ظهور فيه علامه تقارب في لغه الجسد ظهور
الاخت كانت بظهور قوي نعتت رئيس
كوريا الجنوبيه بانها عقد قويه فما كان
لظهور اخته قرب جسدي او قرب عاطفي منه بل
على العكس هو فضل ظهوره مع بنته او فضل
ظهوره مع زوجته بهذا الظهور العاطفي